taking a little ride
this training as a race car driver
starts right now ari lyon dyke jr is
having an
extra special father's day weekend being
the proud dad of new twins with wife
lauren burnham
i mean i'm so excited the bachelor
nation couple welcomed the boy and girl
twins last week
and on sunday lauren shared these
adorable pics to instagram
and wrote cena james and lux jacobs
in the comments lauren confirmed the
name cena has a special meaning for
their racing family
it's inspired by legendary race car
driver ayrton cena
we are headed down to see our little
girl this is your baby brother
you want to see this thing the twins
joined two-year-old big sister
alessi seen here looking over joy to be
with her new siblings
we gotta go talk to our baby girls
doctor first and see if she can come
with us
following the births baby cena had to
remain in the hospital
due to breathing issues which the couple
elaborated on in a video shared to their
youtube page
she's not on oxygen she's perfectly
healthy her development's just a little
bit behind so she gets really relaxed
her heart rate slows down because of her
breathing slowing
and that is concerning you know because
you don't want to
take her home and then have something
happen so they're just being extra extra
careful which i appreciate but
uh still a little bit heartbreaking on
saturday ari shared that lauren
actually surprised him by bringing cena
home for the first time
ari wrote quote best early father's day
gift
our baby girl is home lauren
elizabeth burnham will you marry me
definitely and baby cena's racing
inspired name
is on theme in more ways than one as
lauren told et that before her and ari
fell in love on the bachelor
they actually met for the first time on
a race track
i forgot that you at one point revealed
that you and ari had
briefly met before the show so how did
you wind up going on the show did you
apply yourself was it because you'd met
ari
so i actually met him before i even went
to the casting so
it was totally separate which is crazy
in itself but
um yeah i met him at a racetrack and
then three months later
a lot of my friends from virginia
they're all married and engaged and
they're like there's casting in dallas
you have to go
this time this place just like let us
know what it's like
so i was like okay fine i went and then
i just kept making it through the next
round next round
and they actually told me that they
wanted me to be on the show before they
told me who the bachelor was
so they're like you're gonna have to
watch good morning america to find out
who that is
and so i'm watching good morning america
and he walks out on the stage and i'm
like
what like what are the odds that i meet
this guy
the same summer that i'm cast to go on
this show and he was on it like five
years
ago it was just an incredible
[Music]
coincidence